[Applause]
it was a moment the people of Mali hoped
would Usher lasting peace after years of
brutal
conflict but almost a decade on Marley's
military jent appears to have cast a
death nail on the peace
deal the transitional government notes
the absolute inapplicability of the
agreement for peace and Reconciliation
in Mali issued from the algers Accord
signed in 2015 and consequently
announces its end with immediate
effect analysts say the announcement
reflects the reality for communities
trapped in months of
fighting Marley's Army is also now
accusing Algeria a key mediator in the
2015 deal of changing its posture and
exercising hostile
acts but algers says its contribution is
in promoting peace and respects Marley's
territorial integrity neria has always
treated Northern Mali as this kind of
influence area I mean they had
independently of you know diplomatic
relations also held contacts with with
the rebels with with tux even apparently
with Jadis and other figures and you
know the malians were all kind of
suspecting algerians they want to keep
the bad guys which they're also in
Algeria out of Aleria let them in do
their own thing in Northern
Mali the last un peacekeepers withdrew
from Mali at the end of
2023 it followed tense relations with
the government in Bako after the
military seized power and cases of
violence are already increasing Felix
Nara Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer